my head is throbbing I haven't felt this
dehydrated since my bachelor party
because it turns out that salty
delicious leftist tears are a diuretic
and I believe I overdid it a little bit
yesterday the left is very very angry
they're tweeting all sorts of profanity
at me and other conservatives Trump
voters they're hysterical they're even
more profane than usual because the new
slightly more originalist Supreme Court
majority could deal a blow to the fake
constitutional right to abortion well to
them I say sticks and stones may break
my bones but we're gonna overturn roe v
wade ha we will analyze the probability
of restoring constitutional governance
in other news racist Democrats racism
finally starts to bite them back and
then I call out Matt Walsh's globalism
finally the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
I I can't I can't I can't do it anymore
with the Globes I'm sick of the Globes I
can't no more Globes Matt Walsh is
responsible for this
this isn't matt Walsh's fault look I'm
not opposed to stupid stick on my show I
actually love it it makes up about 3/4
of my show but I'm sick of the globe's I
am NOT a globalist okay the globalism is
a false song and we're rid of it now
because of this administration and
President Trump if you haven't seen the
Matt Walsh show is responsible for the
just play the clip wit ends for good
reason because a globe when you add a
globe into the situation it immediately
makes everything classier and more
professional and more intelligent so
even though I don't have a real studio
or a real set I do have the globe and
the point that I made was well yeah the
other guys at the Daily wire they've got
a studio they've got a set they don't
have a globe though do they
so who really has the most professional
show with the daily wire that that was
that was my argument anyway but after
the show a lot of people informed me
that actually Clavin does have a globe
on his set I never noticed it before but
I went back and I and I watched and yeah
there is kind of off in the corner it's
not displayed prominently like my globe
but he does have a globe so this is what
I'm gonna do I didn't want to have to do
this but I'm going to add a second globe
and so now I have the most Globes both
in terms of globe quantity and also
total global fall yoom and if it's
really necessary for me to pull out the
big guns and I and I'm kind of hesitant
here because I well I don't mean the
show off but if I really need to
I also have this and I could do the
entire show with this globe as well and
what would look more professional or
more intelligent than that okay but i
won't i won't yeah unless it's really
necessary so look like usual I'm
watching the Matt wall
show and I found this argument sort of
convincing because I'll turn into the
Matt Walsh show whenever I can't just
talk to Paul bois I will turn into his
doppelganger Matt Walsh and I will hear
exactly the same voice and the same you
know points of view but with more Globes
so I thought this is kind of compelling
I mean I've been into a lot of sort of
pretentious homes and offices and they
do they have globes and everything so
but then I there was something about the
Globes that I didn't want to be outdone
you know I added the glows to my set
there's something I didn't like about
them I realized what it was
do you know what this looks like yeah
yeah it looks like a soccer ball that's
what it looks like and it reminded me
that basically on this globe every
single place on here except for oh we're
oh except for right there every place on
that globe likes soccer
except for that nice little spot right
there you know that hope of that beacon
of freedom and hope for the entire world
that protects everybody from chaos and
death that one right there doesn't like
soccer so I'm done with the Globes the
fall song of globalism is over Matt
Walsh can keep his Globes I'm done we've
got a lot to talk about today we've got
so much to talk about this replacement
for Justice Kennedy we've got the New
York Times attacking the New York Times
which is a beautiful thing a lot to
celebrate why the Democrats are finally
reaping the rewards of the awful racism
that they've sown for a long time all of
this is coming to a head in this Supreme
Court fight we're gonna say who should
be on who should be on the list who
shouldn't be who should get the
nomination who shouldn't a lot of people
up for it right now we have Mike Lee the
great Senator Mike Lee is up for it some
conservatives are applauding that I'm a
little I don't know if we should appoint
a senator we will discuss all of that
before we do that we got to make a
little money honey what do you think
these Globes are free we got a
production budget isn't how completely
blown out because of this stupid Matt
Walsh gag
so we got to think ring ring is a talk
about safety talk about the 21st century
you know ring is a the video doorbell
company you've seen them all of your
cool friends probably have it it's that
video doorbell you go you click on it
and it opens up a communication line
between the owner of the house and you
so if you're on either you're in the
house
you're at work you're on a beach in in
Boca I don't know where you are and you
can see the people who are outside you
can talk to them all that video is
uploaded to the clouds of some kind of
bad guy wants to come up and either
break into your house or steal your
packages from you know whatever online
shopping you've been doing you can see
them even if they steal your ring video
doorbell it's alright it's already in
the cloud you can share it with friends
it's what the neighborhood watch used to
be now that is totally at passe and how
to favor this is the new way to keep you
and your home safe so i'll set this up
because they sent me clips sometimes of
ring in action a crazy-looking guy walks
up to a home the first thing you hear is
him kicking in the door but then ring
kicks in hello hey leave my house I'm
calling the police
okay what you need to do hey there's my
house stop now or I'm calling the police
why would you tell me that because
you're trying to push my door in leave
now I'm calling the police
okay that guy's not the police the
police usually that guy had about 30% of
his teeth I think the police have a
higher tooth retention average so anyway
it's it's really good I mean I'm joking
about it it really is indispensable
technology I love mine seriously all of
my friends who bought houses use this
technology it's so good and it's so
inexpensive when you think neighborhood
watch use to take up so much time it
wasn't that effective so you know time
is money this is really really
inexpensive thieves just can't hide with
ring stop crime before it happens and
help make your neighborhood safer with
ring right now you can save up to $150
on a ring security kit at ring comm
slash and olds keno wles
that is a huge discount on extremely
reasonably priced technology to begin
with go to ring.com slash Knolls keno
wles $150 off when you go to ring.com
slash and Knolls I really really like
mine
and you know I just feel safer with it
and and you should to it so it's a
wonderful piece of technology okay let's
get to it before we get to the court and
the real decisions here over who's gonna
replace Justice Kennedy I've got to
mention this this I almost I had to
double down on my hangover because now
New York Times editors are admitting
that their paper is just pure garbage
so Jill Abramson former editor of the
New York Times she tweets out she says
it kind of pisses me off that the New
York Times is still asking who is Ocasio
Cortez that was the Socialists who won
the the Congress primary in Queens the
other night when it should have covered
her campaign missing her rise is akin to
not seeing Trump's win coming in 2016
which by the way is obviously a dig at
the New York Times because the New York
Times didn't see Trump's win coming they
didn't think it was even possible the
Trump would win in 2016 they're lashing
out at this and it confirms something
that we've been talking about for a long
time Jill Abramson is no conservative
Republican but far from it but she's
noticing the extreme drop in quality at
the New York Times I think I said this
yesterday the New York Times right now
and occupy Democrats Facebook page or
basically of the same quality I don't
know the difference when it pops up in
my newsfeed a New York Times headline or
or some radical left meme I don't know
which is which
the New York Times now is funding this
cartoon series of like fat cartoons of
Donald Trump looks like ren and stimpy
making out with vladimir putin and
really graphic visuals in many ways the
occupy democrats facebook page has
better taste and more class than the New
York Times does these days there it is
isn't just conservatives pointing this
out and this isn't just the normal tug
and pull of left and right the left is
finally recognizing that they themselves
have hollowed out their institutions so
what the left does is it comes into
institutions and it destroys them we're
seeing it at my dear old alma mater Yale
is like the prime example at the
universities the left goes into
universities destroys them it did this
to all of the mainstream media outlets
and even the New York Times it is
recognizing that that
happened to itself it is a shadow of
what it once was
it doesn't do it doesn't serve its
function in politics in society than it
used to but don't take my word for it
take Jill Abramson's word for it so now
this will play in a little later with
this court fight let's get to the court
the left is so angsty right now they're
so upset about Kennedy who is gonna
replace Kennedy before we get into that
I do have to point out a little
conspiracy theory of mine it was one of
the best memes that was going on around
Twitter yesterday so Mitch McConnell is
key here right Mitch McConnell is the
key a couple nights ago a group of
protesters came up to Mitch McConnell
and his wife another administration
official and they started heckling him
and yelling and Mitch McConnell's wife
told them stop messing with my husband
here's the clip
so the next day after a bunch of lefty
protesters harass Mitch McConnell and
his wife the swing vote on the Supreme
Court retires and Trump is going to
appoint an originalist that cocaine
Mitch baby that you don't mess with
cocaine Mitch that's where he got you
know Don Blankenship was that guy he was
running sort of against Mitch McConnell
he was running this campaign against
Senate leadership and against Mitch he
called him cocaine Mitch and then when
that guy lost Mitch put a picture of
himself as Pablo Escobar he said thanks
for playing this guy man don't mess with
Mitch McConnell you know I love this a
video of him kind of just sitting there
and then then he just slowly looks up
and smiles just then that little of
McConnell smile and that's called a
McConnell in now this is the sort of
stuff don't mess with I don't know if he
like made a deal with the devil for his
powers or something but man guy seems to
just control the universe with his
finger so Democrats are threatening all
sorts of stuff now they're saying we're
gonna you know you and this and you and
because you remember Mitch McConnell is
the reason that we got Neil Gorsuch
Mitch McConnell is the reason that
Merrick garland Barack Obama's nominee
to the court didn't make it onto the
Supreme Court he said note we're not
gonna sit him and so the Democrats are
saying we're gonna do that to you and
you're and now you're gonna see this and
do it no but you know what you can do
Democrats nothing you're totally totally
screwed they can't do they have nothing
at their disposal right now to stop this
nomination and Democrat I am only
rubbing their face in it because they
have nobody to blame but themselves this
was caused by Democrats in 2013 when
Harry Reid invoked the nuclear option so
the nuclear option was saying you no
longer need more than a simple majority
to confirm judicial nominees and Mitch
McConnell warned about this he actually
there he is cocaine Mitch
Ward he said you are gonna regret this
here's Mitch McConnell once again Senate
Democrats are threatening to break the
rules of the Senate break the rules of
the Senate in order to change the rules
of the Senate and over what over what
over a quart that doesn't even have
enough work to do the majority leader
promised he promised over and over again
that he wouldn't break the rules of the
Senate in order to change them if you
want to play games set yet another
precedent that you will no doubt come to
regret say to my friends on the other
side of the aisle you'll regret this and
you may regret it a lot sooner than you
think
sitting there like Tony Soprano or
something you know like I think you're
gonna regret this if it was me I
wouldn't do it I wouldn't do it Harry
mmm I don't think and so what they did
Harry Reid pushes the nuclear option and
that made it such that you only need a
simple majority to get through judicial
nominees except for the Supreme Court
this didn't include the Supreme Court
but of course at this point after he's
gone to the nuclear option it's now up
to Merrick garland and Harry Reid no
longer has control of the Senate what is
Mitch McConnell gonna do Mitch McConnell
now the leader of the Senate he is a
totally railroads Merrick garland he
says we're not going to do it it's an
election year and you can't make us do
it so now we've got this you know we
still have the majority in the Senate
and I got to tell you something they're
saying it's gonna be really hard to get
Trump's nominee through because Susan
Collins and other left-wing Republicans
are gonna stop it you know liberal
Republicans squishes they don't want an
originalist judge I don't know about
that there are a lot of Democrats who
are in states with a lot of Trump voters
and Trump is very popular right now and
his policies are very very popular right
now I'm not so sure that they'll be able
to railroad him on a party-line vote
what about Joe Manchin joe Manchin in
West Virginia is he really reliable to
to not support Trump's nominee Joe
Manchin needs those Trump voters Claire
McCaskill in Missouri John tester
Montana they're in a really tough spot
so it's true we've got to deal with
Susan Collins and our squishes but what
about their guys III don't know Trump is
very popular right now there's that by
the way he's like we're talking about
almost record levels of popularity
there's a new study out from Harvard
Capps and Harris Trump
rural rating is it 47% this is up two
points from last month so think about
what's been happening in the last month
in the last month the mainstream media
shows pictures of babies crying they're
totally made-up pictures by the way but
you know babies being ripped from their
mother utter fiction and they put it on
the cover of the Time magazine with
Photoshop and you know there's it's so
awful in that terrible and what happens
to Trump's popularity it ticks up two
points and that by the way that it's not
like it went up with the Republicans a
lot and down a little bit with the
Democrats it went up six points among
Republican voters it went up three
points among Democrat voters and it went
up ten points among Hispanics so you
would think this is the moment yeah
we're gonna demagogue Democrats are
gonna make this all about race and blah
blah blah it's gonna kill them with the
Hispanic vote uh uh it went up 10 points
so what are these guys gonna do these
Senate Democrats are they really gonna
say no no Trump we're gonna obstruct the
whole way okay good enjoy your
re-election campaigns guys good keep
that up there that that'll probably work
in this other this poll also showed 59%
of Americans approve Donald Trump's
handling of North Korea and 75% approve
the Kim meeting three-quarters of
Americans approve him meeting with Kim
jong-un so okay guys run against Trump
obstruct Donald Trump be my guest
see how that works out for you the left
is furious about this position they're
not just the retirement of Kennedy not
just that we're gonna get another
originalist on the court they're furious
because they can't do anything about it
here's Chris Matthews well I don't think
we're looking at their most the fresher
history here of this 5-4 court of course
as John mentioned Jon Meacham just
mentioned they were the ones who'd throw
the election through the election took
it out of the hands of the Supreme Court
down in Florida gave it to a george w
bush and then of course they gave the
gun people what they wanted in the
Heller decision then they gave them
money people that decision they wanted
in the United Citizens United then of
course just yesterday they gave the
anti-immigrant people what if they this
this Supreme Court this 5-4 Court has
been Pro Republican pro-gun Pro money
and against immigration anti-immigrant
any anti-immigrant if you will and I
think the Democrats as I said a few
moments ago have to fight this tooth
that now they have to use every process
opportunity I had to stop this until
next year we have a
you senate we don't know where the next
year's Senate will be Republican or
Democratic dama dama nated but to give
this to the Republicans when they
control the Senate basically 51 or 52 49
really with John McCain perhaps not
voting again to giving this last chance
to pack the court 5-4 again hard
conservative I again I say this the base
will attack the leadership for this if
they allow it to happen and they should
because this is time for vengeance for
what happened two years ago and if they
don't reap the vengeance now with four
and a half weeks four and a half months
to go before the election they will not
look very strong to their base and I
think they'll be under attack vengeance
that's that is the left-wing agenda
right now because listen to how he talks
but first of all it's very hard because
he just kind of mumbles and make some
immigrant people and the money people
and the blood blood with them know that
this Court has ruled in favor of the
Constitution usually it's ruled in favor
of the Constitution it's it's it's ruled
in favor of the gun advocates right
because the Constitution is a gun
advocate the Constitution protects your
individual right to keep and bear arms
it's ruled in favor of uh you know being
able to donate money to political
candidates right because the First
Amendment allows you to donate money to
political candidates because you have
free political speech yeah of course duh
duh but he look whatever they're as I
said yesterday they're kind of coming
clean here right they're saying it we
oppose the Constitution we oppose they
said he says that the the court is
anti-immigrant it's not anti-immigrant
it's Pro Constitution the constitutional
as the legislature to legislate and the
the executive to execute to execute
those laws so they're but they're being
honestly saying we're anti-constitution
you're right the left base is anti
Constitution anti-american and and he
says the base is going to be really
angry if the Democrats don't try to shut
this down yeah they will but you know
who's really unpopular in America right
now the Democrat base the left that far
left base which is holding the Democrat
Party hostage is very unpopular so good
do it put them on display put them all
over TV that's great can't wait to see
in November that'll be that's a great
idea
other other Democrats are pretty upset
about this too a u.s. reprimand Boyle
said quote the GOP theft of a Supreme
Court seat by blocking Merrick
garland is possibly the single most
consequential political act of this
decade the that it is it is the most
consequential political act by the way
it's not a theft of course we'll get to
that in a second but Mitch McConnell was
asked about this he said he said you
know what in your career Mitch McConnell
has been in government since I think
1628 in your career what's what's the
most important thing you've ever done he
said holding up the nomination of
Merrick garland is the most
consequential act of my career and
that's absolutely true because it we get
we got to give this guy credit for it
he made it such that the conservative
base was ready and raring to go to elect
President Trump to deal you know maybe
some people were skeptical of him he
didn't have much of a political record
but they went because it's it's so so
mattered plus it gave us this Court
which has given us wonderful
pro-constitution pro-american decisions
decisions on free speech religious
liberty on life I mean really really
good stuff poised to be another one you
know if the if the conservatives who
didn't want to vote for Trump had gotten
their way we'd have two justices right
now we'd have a 6-3 a left-wing majority
on the court what would happen to your
gun rights well we know Hillary Clinton
told us they'd go away what would happen
to your First Amendment rights Hillary
Clinton told us they'd go away then left
I mean and by the way the left isn't
even hiding this anymore op-ed after
op-ed politician after politicians think
we need to censor speech this is a great
win and we got to thank Mitch for that
but to call it theft they're saying he's
stolen it was unfair he stolen it's
theft he where I wonder where Mitch
McConnell got that idea from I
threatened you I told you I would play
this clip take it away Joe Biden it is
my view that if a Supreme Court justice
resigns tomorrow or within the next
several weeks or resigns at the end of
the summer
President Bush should consider following
the practice of a majority of his
predecessors and not and not name a
nominee until after the November
election is completed well that's
awkward isn't it the once and future
candidate he's going to run again
by the way Joe Biden he just is someone
asked me I said are you gonna run for
president in 2020 he said I really don't
want to I really don't want to I've seen
how terrible it I don't you don't want
to you've been running for presidents
since the 80s of course you are you
kidding me you that's the job you've
held in your life is trying to be
president oh I don't want to that's what
disingenuous politicians who have run
for office who have already run for
president multiple times they say I
don't want to of course you want to
you've just said you want to you want to
do for 30 years yeah so but it's a
little awkward because that guy is the
one who created the premise for Mitch
McConnell to hold up that nomination now
look obviously this is just politics if
you have the ability to stop that
nomination if you have the political
capital to do it and get your guy in
you're going to do that that's just
politics now the left is trying to use
this they're trying to flip it right and
say oh well we've got an election coming
up it's a midterm election it's not a
presidential election but whatever oh
yeah we have a mint so you know Ezra
Klein is saying it's hypocritical for
Republicans to want this nomination to
go through before the election Cory
Booker is saying the same thing he's
saying come on you've got you've got to
do it yeah okay that's a stretch that is
a real stretch fellas I'm sorry you know
the only way that this works that the
Joe Biden's speech or Mitch McConnell
the way that they're able to hold up
these nominations is if they have the
political capital to do it if there's a
Senate majority and they can stretch
that political capital long enough to
get through the election then they're
going to do it Democrats don't have that
right now they don't have the majority
in the house they don't have the
majority in the Senate they're not very
popular the president is very popular
it's not a presidential election it's a
midterm election sorry you lose too bad
and the other aspect here by the way
when you hear people preening about this
because I've noticed sometimes the the
rank-and-file on the Left are doing this
to their their I think they're genuinely
outraged because they're ignorant
sergej say what McConnell did this and
we should they're right so I basically
favor David Mayhew the political
scientist David Mayhew I side with him
here this guy one of the major
accomplishments of his career that he
demonstrated is something very simple
but very profound which is that members
of Congress are motivated basically
solely by reelect
every single decision that a member of
Congress makes is made with regard to
how it effects his chances at
re-election that that you know it
basically with a few exceptions I'm
actually friends with some people who
have served in Congress and there are
exceptions that prove the rule but the
rule broadly is that the people who go
there are sociopaths
they're just sociopaths egotist trying
to make sure that they stay in power
Madison James Madison wrote about this
in Federalist 51 very clearly he said
ambition must be made to counteract
ambition meaning we're going to put all
of the crazy sociopaths who want to take
over the country we're gonna put them in
a room and have them fight each other
and therefore their ambition is going to
counter one another that's what you see
here but it is a total farce I mean it
is naked politics and that's fine they
can preen all they want that's kind of
the purpose of the Senate and the
Congress as the Federalist lays out but
for people who are like regular people
in the world you shouldn't fall for that
you shouldn't take that seriously it's
naked politics and and the Democrats
don't have it right now they can't do it
I suppose Joe Biden wanted them to hold
it up in 92 maybe they could have had
the political capital Devin I don't have
it now and we did have it in the 2016
election and thank goodness we did
because it preserved American liberty
and it just knocked away a lot of
nonsense that will give us the
opportunity possibly to to maintain
Liberty in America at least for a little
while so the question on everybody's
mind it's the title today the title
today is just I took roe v wade and I
flipped it upside down I overturned it
mmm is are we gonna overturn roe v wade
the famous decision decades old now
nineteen early 1970s the the decades-old
decision that pretended that there's
some constitutional right to abortion
which obviously there is not there yet
you know I sometimes reference I got to
meet Scalia twice and he answered like
every legal question I've ever had so I
referenced this a lot but that you know
if you want a law allowing abortion
that's fine
I mean it's wrong and evil and immoral
and you'll probably burn in hell but but
I suppose it's as a matter of Republican
politics that's fine but you have to go
and convince your fellow citizens your
neighbors to agree with you
and then you can pass a law and then you
can have abortion what's really wrong to
do the really legally wrong thing to do
is to pretend that it's in the
Constitution somewhere look in the
Constitution and show me the right to
abortion look in the Constitution and
show me the redefinition of marriage to
include but only include same-sex unions
in addition to traditional unions to
same-sex monogamous unions of two people
find me that in the Constitution but not
polygamous unions because that's not in
there because they're just reading
things they're inventing it in the
Constitution there is no right to
abortion in the Constitution roe v wade
is one of the worst decisions if not the
worst decision ever made by the Supreme
Court and the question is now that we
have the squish can it be gone who's
sort of conservative a lot of the time
but crucially sometimes he's pretty
besides with the left will we be able to
overturn roe v wade if there's an
abortion case that comes up to the court
will we be able to overturn it the
question is Roberts Roberts clearly has
an institutional view of the court he's
worried about the institution of the
Supreme Court if the people get too
angry they could just do away with it
someday so he sided with the Liberals on
the on Obamacare
for instance when it was obviously
unconstitutional would he do that on roe
v wade I don't know I mean he's a he's a
conservative but he does have that
institutional view and it might a wrong
view of the institutional view could
lead him down the path of not wanting to
overturn it there is the question of
story decisis the the legal idea that
precedent matters you know that if
something was decided a long time ago or
has been reaffirmed that you have to
give that some credit even even if
perhaps it's on shaky legal grounds are
we going to overturn you know you know
the I mean I guess the question on story
decisis we ask this to Scalia to is how
do you judge that you know I mean
Justice Thomas Clarence Thomas doesn't
seem to care very much about story
decisis in a way that Scalia did and you
know without story decisis you just have
chaos you know very important rulings
could just be totally upended left and
right so you do have to have some view
of the tradition of legal precedent but
we asked him we said what about roe v
wade and he said you know some decisions
are
so egregious that they have to be
overturned even if that upsets story
decisis and in some come to mind you
know the Dred Scott decision saying that
that black people can never be citizens
in the United States well you know I
actually sort of defend that decision
because it not for the effect of it but
what it did was it showed the American
law to be as it was it showed the
absurdity of the question of racial
basis for slavery and so it spurred a
revision of that what but you know
obviously on its face just just awful
consequences from that decision
how about Plessy be Ferguson that
maintains separate but equal but of
course those separate things were not
equal some cases are so egregious that
you have to flip them and more than any
you could point to roe v wade which has
resulted in the deaths of millions and
millions of babies and we kill a million
babies a year because of roe v wade
now if roe v wade were overturned that
doesn't mean the abortions illegal it
means that states would decide means
that you know the New York and
California if you want to keep killing
your babies you pass a law that doesn't
it doesn't say that there's a
constitutional protection against
abortion but it just says there's no
constitutional right to abortion and now
the another consideration of Susan
Collins is she gonna make us just get
another Kennedy basically another
squishy non originalist justice maybe
but as I said earlier I'm not certain of
that I am certain of this whoever is
nominated by Donald Trump for the
supreme court needs to go into those
hearings and when asked about roe v--
wade which he will be countless times
say roe v-- wade has defined the law of
the land and is the law of the land at
his roe v-- wade is settled and that's
all he should say about it
because that's all true it is settled
was settled forty years ago it is true
that it's defined the law of the land
all true until we overturn it and and
then it won't be settled well it'll be
unsettled and then we'll have a new
settlement then we'll have a new law of
the land but that's all that that person
should say obviously we don't want
someone to get borked because they've
got the pro-lifers or what you know they
went to Catholic Mass one time so
they're clearly
to pro-life or they've read the
Constitution right go in there you say
roe v-- wade is the settled law of the
land you get a little smirk in there
what was that smirks excuse me judge
Pryor what was that smirk oh nothing hmm
what what smirk what do you think about
roe v-- wade Oh Ravi wait is in the
settled law of the land
no I saw that again no you didn't see
anything that's what we need to do so
the question is before we get to the
mailbag now who should we get who
they're good judges on the short list
I'm not gonna pretend that I know
everything about all these judges at all
but I will talk about the ones who are
getting a lot of discussion in the
mainstream media Mike Lee terrific
senator very conservative one of the
best members of the US Senate a terrific
politician in America I don't know that
he should go to the Supreme Court I
don't know that he should I don't know
that in this particularly polarized time
while conservatives are struggling to
explain to Democrats that and if to
explain to the left broadly that the
Supreme Court is supposed to be
nonpartisan that we favor originalist
sand textualist s-- because they respect
the letter of the law of the
Constitution regardless of our political
preferences that we're not nominating
conservatives or Republicans were
nominating original lists and here is an
example of a difference a conservative
justice would say that abortion is
illegal because we want to protect life
an originalist justice would say there's
no protection there's no right to an
abortion doesn't mean that abortion is
necessarily illegal then does it their
laws against murder you need a law
against abortion that would be a
difference between that kind of
jurisprudence as we're trying to
convince them of this difference as
we're trying to maintain the integrity
of the court I don't know that it looks
good to a point a senator a conservative
Republican senator not nothing against
Mike Lee Mike Lee would be terrific on
the court but we haven't had a senator
serve on the Supreme Court since 1971
since Hugo black and that was the last
year that we had a senator on the court
and Hugo black was terrible
member of the Klan Democrat and which is
that sums I'm repeating myself a new
dealer he voted for some of the worst
decisions Wickard V filburn totally
expanded federal power
as a senator he vehemently opposed anti
lynching legislation you know just
absolutely terrible
so I guess Mike Lee could be our version
of that he's like the good version of a
senator on the court but I just don't in
this very partisan ideological woman I
don't know we can do it obviously a
Howard Taft William Howard Taft was both
president and chief justice of the court
he was president first and then until 20
1913 and then he was chief justice for
the 1920s basically so I don't know I'm
a little dubious on putting a senator on
the court the the leading contender
right now is William Pryor from the 11th
Circuit Court of Appeals
listen Republican presidents have gotten
burned before by judicial nominees I we
need someone who is who we know about
and we know a lot about and we can sort
of rely on Pryor is that sort of
rock-ribbed originalist I think from
everything I know about him I also like
that he's Catholic and I'll and it's not
just my own Catholic bias coming out
here Catholics make great justices
Scalia Alito Thomas converted to
Catholicism we reverted to Catholicism
Gorsuch is a cradle Catholic I think now
he goes to a Protestant Church in a
Piscopo Church twice the liturgy half
the guilt but still has that kind of
Catholic upbringing the recent cafe
there are other Catholics too the reason
the Catholics are good on the court is
because it's a real institution that
looks at tradition and you know is a
horse's logic very very tightly and
Catholics are known for this Catholics
have been doing this for 2,000 years
you know the Thomas Aquinas is a good
example here long-standing institutions
seriousness you know bringing ancient
understandings of logic through into the
modern world so they're very good at
this and I so I do favor Catholics in
that way plus Catholics like to wear
weird long robes and stuff and go into a
kind of old building so they're good at
that another one who's being talked
about is I'm wolf thought par he is a
little younger than prior prior is 56
sipar is under 50 and he's on the Sixth
Circuit Court of Appeals he's really
tied with Mitch McConnell who have been
extolling the virtues of the last couple
days we know a little less about him so
I don't know he could be terrific he
could be great he's
not a Catholic but I won't hold it
against him I won't totally hold it
against him Mike Lee is not a Catholic
either one hold it against him but but I
don't know we know a little less about
him so I'm a little worried because
we've been burned before we'll just have
to see what happens but it would be
terrific the Democrats really shot down
Pryor last time because they said he was
to rock-ribbed a constitutionalist would
be really nice to drink up those tears
if we got him this time wouldn't it now
it would be I'd have to get like two ice
packs next time before we get to the
mailbag I know we're running out of time
a little bit here as we're talking about
demographics got to talk about that
Democrat tribalism fighting them
Alexandria Acacio Cortez is is
campaigned on the slogan basically women
like me aren't supposed to run for
office she was you know the Socialists
who won in Queens and where's she
talking about a left winger I don't
think she was talking about that I think
she's talking about her race and her
gender and her demographics her you know
sort of physical demographics she's 28
years old she's Hispanic and apparently
this endowed you with super powers now
if you're a Democrat you know just your
sort of ethnicity or race your gender we
saw this with Sotomayor speaking of the
court when Sonia Sotomayor was nominated
by Obama she said you know you need a
wise Latino woman on the court as though
you know that so now that now you know
Antonin Scalia says you need someone who
understands the Constitution and
Sotomayor says you need a wise latina
woman yeah okay but what's great about
this we're seeing this in a lot of races
around the country not just in Queens at
the Catskills this guy Antonio Delgado
who's this Harvard and Oxford grad he's
a black candidate he beat out six white
Democrat candidates recently Maryland
Democrats nominated Ben Jealous for
governor a hundred fifty one women so
far in this cycle have one House
Democrat primaries that's twice as many
as at this point in 2016
what that's showing us is that they're
really digging into this racial and
gender intersectionality you know we're
gonna now look some some of these people
are good candidates the the Harvard
Oxford guy is obviously you know
credentialed and qualified but it does
seem that there's a real uptick in in
those considerations and it shows the
end of I
in some ways the end of the Democrat
Party because they're saying we're going
to privilege race and gender you know
people who aren't white men we're gonna
privilege that over other you know other
characteristics such as ideology you
know it doesn't seem like that race in
the Catskills doesn't look like ideology
played much of a role in it you know
it's it's they're really digging into
not the thought process but just the the
looks the looks of things we're in a
time that has passed logic we talked
about after World War one this breakdown
of logic and sense and art and now we're
in this just like grunting tribalism and
the Democrats are digging in more than
anybody it looks like it's gonna bite
them though because that's not a that's
not a serious and logical way to make
decisions you want to you want to pick a
candidate not because of the color of
their skin but because of the content of
their character and their logic and
their their platform on what they're
gonna run on so we'll see and it I can't
imagine it's gonna help them we got to
get to the mailbag before I get to that
I've got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube in the last minutes here go over
to Daily wire calm ten bucks them on
four hundred dollars for an annual
membership you get me get the end
replevin sure you get the Ben Shapiro
show you get to ask questions in the
mail bag by the way we've got a great
daily wire backstage coming up that is
gonna be on July 2nd I think we doing
that on the second
yes July 2nd 7:00 p.m. Eastern Time
we've got the guest Jordin B Peterson
there so if you're a subscriber you get
to go and you get to ask questions and
we can do that but again none of it
matters
look you're gonna get a hangover so make
sure you drink a lot of water door over
the next couple of weeks but you need
this vessel otherwise otherwise you're
gonna drown go get the leftist ears
tumblr daily wire comm we'll be right
back with the mailbag
we've got about six minutes here at the
end so I'm gonna try to get a lot of
mailbag questions in first question from
Paul why does the Catholic Church insist
that only men can be priests it's
because the thurible czar very heavy
they're very heavy it's hard to pick
them up the smells and the bells you
need a lot of muscles for that to work
there's some other there are some other
reasons too
but this question actually does come up
a lot why why can't women be priests I
think you're looking at it backwards
first of all priestesses have been
common to a lot of religions in
antiquity and in the modern era you know
before during and after the Incarnation
it's not like this was unheard of and
only and only we blessed moderns realize
that women can do things that isn't what
happened but Judaism rejected that and
it seems that Christ and establishing
the church did not want women to be
priests either how do we know that well
if he did the Virgin Mary would have
been an ideal candidate to be a priest
right at the sacrament of at the Blessed
Sacrament at the Eucharist she could
have quite literally said this is my
body this is my blood right it comes
from from her the Christ comes from her
from her womb but women and men have
different roles in the church doesn't
mean that women are lesser you'll
remember who was the we were the first
people to spread the gospel of the
Resurrection was women women realized
that that Christ was resurrected but are
they given a teaching function in the
church no we know that from Saint Paul's
epistles from first Corinthians from
first Timothy they have different
function we have nuns we have priests we
have you know in and and women teach in
Catholic schools it's not like they
can't teach ever you know but in the
church there is a different role to them
of the Apostles the Apostles are men the
apostles there are plenty of female
disciples of Jesus were very close to
him and the closest to Jesus is his
mother obviously a woman when when Judas
betrayed Christ and in Acts they the
Apostles elected a new apostle in which
it was just where we get apostolic
succession from who
men and I think there's a reason for
that if you ask the question why can't
women I think you're looking at it from
different ways you know when you're a
priest you're serving the church and
you're serving the bridegroom of the
church Christ it is a service it's
something you do it's not about the
personal will and showing off and having
a flashy title in or something it's
about service and so if you're saying
well I want that glory you're doing it
wrong in the 1970s the the Church of
England started to ordain women priests
it was the beginning of the end of the
Church of England I don't know if
anybody goes there anymore
it's like a husk of a husk now you know
and it was there was a big split there
was a lot of Anglo Catholicism that came
out of that the reason that women aren't
priests in the church is that women
aren't priests in the church and if
someone is really enraged by this it
probably says more about you than about
the church and maybe you'll have to
think where that rage comes from from
Alicia hi Mikey hey Alicia I have
enjoyed your comments on the Catholic
Church and practices on a spectrum of
one to ten one being guitar group modern
and ten being rigged or Ian chant what
type of church do you prefer
Alicia 11 from Brandon Michael you're
nearing your prophecy 200th episode what
steps have you taken to avoid your
homeless dumpster living calamity you're
married now where will that poor woman
live you have to think about these
things it has been weighing on me you
know I love reading like Odysseus the
Odyssey and the Iliad sometimes the
fates really can conspire against you
the more you try to change your fate the
the more you lead yourself into it I'm
working on it it is true that 200th
episode where I'm bearded and living in
a dumpster it is coming up I'm sleeping
with one eye open at night I'm doing my
BAE if you have any thoughts please
tweet them at me I've had to avoid that
terrible terrible fate where we got a
few more minutes from Corrie dear sweet
little ol Michael you said yesterday
that the philosophical premise of owning
your own body leads to modernism well I
said that is part and parcel of
modernism that's actually the the
philosophical premises of modernism or
what leads you to think ridiculous
things like you have your own body I'll
continue with the question even with
libertarians how does this lead
libertarians to asking for consent to
change
diapered who owns your body if not
yourself God which one there are several
different interpretations of God at the
Daily wire can I just pick my favorite
it seems like a lottery ticket that is
usually picked out for you by your
parents your cell mate or your favorite
conservative commentator COFF Clavin
coughs real nice buddy these are genuine
questions no sarcasm Cory first question
who owns your body if not you God yes
God you didn't make your body you're not
responsible for creating your body you
are not you do not belong to yourself it
isn't just a total fiction and a fantasy
to believe that you belong to yourself
you have a will but your will is as a
Tilos and as a purpose there's a purpose
for your life and you don't just get to
make it out of nothing and pick it out
of thin air you can but your life won't
turn out very well you you are do not
own yourself this is why suicide is a
sin you don't own yourself you didn't
create yourself you have no legitimate
right to say I own myself and I can do
with myself as I please including
disregarding the moral order as for
which God to choose from how do you
choose which God very carefully very
carefully that's how you choose which
God you say that there are many
interpretations of versions of God at
the Daily wire I don't think that's true
I suppose a Ben would disagree with drew
and I over the nature of the Incarnation
and the resurrection sure that the
second person of the Trinity maybe the
third person too but if we were to
describe God the Father I don't know
that we would describe him terribly
differently would we that the first
person of the Blessed Trinity I don't
know if we were to describe the moral
order that comes out of God that I don't
know that we were described it terribly
differently would we a lot of people who
want to justify atheism they they say oh
there are so many different versions of
God how can we know they're all people
have different ideas not really not
really I mean there are certainly
heresies that people spout but I don't
if you look at sort of the the myths the
ancient myths and sort of the the
ancient conversations that are happening
between pagans and between people who
believe in God I'm not so sure that
there are different gods that come out
even in even in the polytheistic pagan
elisions I'm not sure that an image of
God isn't at least lightly manifested
that you can sort of see through the fog
I don't really believe that it's why
moral systems around the world are so
similar you know i i've never heard a
really a good argument for atheism I've
never heard a serious person give a
serious argument for atheism because
they don't really exist so you might say
well that's not clear I wanted an answer
I want it to be so clear and obvious
which religion I should believe in and
which God I should worship all shallows
are clear you know or you can you do I
don't know
multivariable calculus are you really
good at that or stochastic analysis or
some sort of difficult you know higher
in math are you really good at are you
perfect at that no probably not you'll
probably don't know very much about that
beyond algebra if you're like the
average American so if you don't know
about that what why on earth would you
think that you can grasp the nature of
God just let just cuz just cuz there's a
great story about st. Agustin was trying
to explain the Trinity this is a legend
that comes from st. Agustin although who
knows maybe it happened I mean he was
really racking his brain and he was
walking along the beach and he saw a
little kid pouring water with a seashell
into a hole and he said to the kid what
are you doing and he said oh I'm I'm
gonna pour the whole ocean into this
hole he said that's great you can't fit
the whole ocean into that hole and then
the kid turns to him and he says that's
right and you can't fit the mystery of
the Trinity into that finite head of
yours and then all of a sudden that you
know that child is transfigured and
disappears I think it's a good you know
it's a it's a legend about st. Agustin
but it's a it's a good story you can't
fit all of that into your head but just
because you have finite intelligence
just because you can't understand
something doesn't mean that that it
doesn't exist you know most of the
things in the world none of us can't
understand we have such a such a finite
intelligence do we have time for one
more we gotta go we gotta go
okay sorry folks but some really good
questions to talk about I will see you
next week we had some really good guests
coming up I don't want to spoil it right
yet but we've got a lot to talk about
today
so we've got a lot to talk about next
week with them in the meantime I hope
that you guys can cure all of your left
is tears hangovers make sure you get the
tumbler I'm Michael nose this is the
Michael Nolt show I'll see you Monday
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018